♫ I wish I could be a Disney Princess
♫ So I could marry a homeless Arabian man
♫ So I could have furniture
as my only friends
♫ And I wish I could be Disney Princess
♫ So I could fight the
Mongolian Army single-handedly
♫ I wish I could be a Disney Princess
♫ So I could live with seven tiny men
♫ If I were a Disney Princess
♫ I would have everything
at my finger tips
♫ I could be Native American
♫ If I were a Disney Princess
♫ I could cry life saving tears
♫ I could resurrect dead men with my tears
♫ Jasmine, I wanna be you, Cinderella
♫ I wanna be you
♫ I just don't wanna be
the part of your life
♫ Where you were a slave
♫ Pocahontas, I wanna be you, Ariel
♫ I wanna be you so I could hang out with
♫ Giant sassy drag queen squids
♫ I wish I could be a Disney Princess
♫ So I could marry some guy
who kisses me as I sleep
♫ And I wish I could be a Disney Princess
♫ So I could be afraid of making ice
♫ 'Cause I don't wanna kill my sister ♫
- Alex, do you wanna play with me?
- No.
- OK!
♫ I wish I could be a Disney Princess
♫ So I could have a man climb up my head ♫
- Yes, yes, yes.
♫ I wish I could be a Disney Princess
♫ So I could have horse mice
♫ I really want horse mice
♫ If I were a Disney Princess
♫ I would have everything
at my finger tips
♫ I could be African American
♫ If I were a Disney Princess
♫ I could go on psychedelic trips
♫ Making tapestries with bears
♫ Aurora, I wanna be you, Snow White
♫ I wanna be you
♫ I just don't wanna be
the part of your life
♫ Where you are poisoned, no
♫ Belle, I wanna be you, Mulan
♫ I wanna be you so that I
could have a sassy dragon
♫ I want a sassy dragon
♫ I wanna be a Disney Princess
♫ And if I were I'd take no
recess to spread the word
♫ That love it's the best
way to live your life
♫ I'd be a handsome man's wife
♫ And we'd kiss, and we'd kiss
♫ And we'd kiss
♫ I wish I could be a Disney Princess
♫ So I could marry a
homeless Arabian man ♫